I'm here with Grand Master Alexander
Linderman who just drew Dennis cadric's
securing first place and called The Fall
chess classic Group B section Alex tell
me how you're feeling man take me
through your game and really just just
take show me how you did it like it's
this pretty uh obviously a great moment
and uh I feel like you're pretty happy
right now no of course yeah it's always
nice to win a tournament special with a
round of Despair which means that I can
just play the last round
um you know without any pressure you
know still enjoy the game and do my best
but without any pressure
um so yeah I think uh yeah I'm pretty
happy with my form in this tournament
played for the most part pretty good
chefs
um so yeah definitely quite happy about
that um in today's game my opponent
um clearly wanted to fight from the very
beginning because he played Knight F3 G3
kind of avoiding a lot of theory and
keeping me at a distance I mean he's
also always playing one E4 but he saw us
playing the Petrov probably didn't want
to go into forcing lines he wanted to
fight
so we got an interesting fight I played
Knight D7 with the idea of playing E5
the main move is D4 but
um
I thought
there's a good chance he'll just play uh
the way he did because he likes this uh
kind of structures with 92 E4 and stuff
like that little door and reversed
because he plays field door with blacks
so I
kind of expected yeah and then we got
this position where
um I was pretty happy here because uh in
in the structure without the Deep ones
um I've been taught that the most
important squares to control are c4 and
C5 and I control C5 quite nicely so I
didn't think I could be worse
um and I told my Bishop on his Bishop on
G2 is not amazing so I thought you know
I could be a bit better but I'm not sure
if I played it uh the best way so
uh just trying to um
get this setup you know obviously I want
to try to protect E5
and uh yeah now I want to play B6 Bishop
A6
um you know and then put the bishop on
C5
where I Target F2 a little bit I mean
I've I've played the structure many
times on the black side of the French
and some lines so I've I was kind of
familiar with how to play it but but
then he played a pretty strong move and
I thought I expected H3 but somehow I
missed that you can play Bishop H3
activating the bishop
and uh
yeah so here's a I spent a long time and
it's a very critical moment because I
was calculating for a while B5 which
apparently
is a good move but I couldn't quite make
it work I thought a b
so Bishop takes the problem is Bishop C3
and I feel like
uh couldn't really make the lines work
whether it's A4 or an ib6
uh and I also saw this move
but uh what did I not like here so if
Knight A5
this should be four I think I saw that
but I thought maybe Knight E3 is what I
calculated
and then I thought Bishop E4 Queen E4
Queen E3 I wrote Queen C2 uh Rook D2 and
he has a very good compensation for the
pawn and I cannot take on e4 I thought
because of oh yeah because the knight's
hanging on D7 so but I could play before
Queen E1 and I still can't take the
phone number apparently I just go but
should be seven in them
better but yeah I couldn't quite
evaluate it so I decided to I mean I did
spend a lot of time here I decided to
play this clumsy mover okay seven it's a
bit weird uh at some point I want to
play B5 but repair maybe with Rook A8 I
just somehow couldn't find uh I mean of
course the idea of B5 is still
eventually go Knight B6 I was also
considering something with 98.96 but if
I go to Q7 I thought maybe Knight H4 I
didn't really want to have to play G6
because then he has this bishop going to
a G7 and stuff it's okay as Rook A7
Bishop C3 and then I was quite happy
with Bishop before
you know just trying to equalize here
um yeah and to be fair I sort of missed
902 but you know it still seems like
it's kind of equalish
uh I mean I guess
yeah I mean I guess the point is that
it's a trick if CB yeah maybe it's uh
Queen C2 Knight D3 it's kind of
some uncomfortability here so but yeah I
saw I couldn't play with short takes and
I thought I don't shouldn't have
problems with endgame because my Rook is
very active actually I thought he'll
play Queen F3
but I guess I'm okay here too but Queen
C7 and stuff but yeah he played this
um
and here I thought I'm I'm okay I
repositioned the bishop to E6
um here I thought he would play a four
but
he decided to just play here
you know it looks like this position is
around equal
uh
yeah I mean actually maybe if I anyone
could and the last important move is
Roque one because if I play Nothing move
um if he wants to play a four here maybe
get some unbalance but by playing Rook I
want I prevent that and now he doesn't
really have any ideas to play for a win
I don't think because of four
oh apparently it's kind of playable but
I didn't think it's because of VC then
very bad structure and after this I
thought I get the phone oh you can I
guess he could take with the Kingman a
rook takes here
um
king of three I guess you could suck the
pawn and not be worse but okay it's I
didn't think I should be a word so yeah
I sort of you know wanted to prevent it
apparently he can still sort of play it
but okay he
he thought for a while and he couldn't
find anything better for than uh to
repeat moves and yeah here maybe I could
like if I was in a different situation
in a regular open term like round one I
could have considered you know like a
neutral move instead of repeating moves
and I mean I'm probably not worse I
could play for a win but on but here of
course yeah basically what happened was
we we just repeated this until move 40
and uh made a draw here so I guess it's
a reasonably good game I kind of kept my
nerves in in Tech and was never really
under big danger
well that's obviously great you're never
willing to get into danger and six and a
half points even though it doesn't
matter too much tomorrow you're gonna
have white against uh Christian torilla
yeah
since the game doesn't matter as much
we'll see you we'll see I mean I didn't
really think about that game so much
because I had no idea how I'll do this
game like if if I were to lose today
then I probably would have just tried to
make a draw with white but now of course
I'll try to fight and we'll we'll see I
don't know I don't know yet I haven't
really thought about it too deeply let's
see obviously you too you take a nice
relaxer and you have a great because you
deserve it man oh thank you so much
that is Grand Master Alex Lenderman our
B group winner taking home four thousand
dollars a very nice interview very
humble and he did actually kind of admit
at the end that you know he was able to
keep his nerves intact which is nice
every interview I've heard it seems like
he's just he feels very solid feels like
nothing's really going on but you know
deep down uh he's really happy with the
results and he totally earned it he
played some really excellent chess here
and really hasn't gotten himself in any
trouble never really having a very bad
position not at all uh all right
Jonathan speaking of winners